[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Spaß
Besuch in Brasilien die Minister Habeck
und Özdemir wollen engere
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen und die
Zusammenarbeit beim Klimaschutz ausbauen
massive Verluste im Kampf um bachmut
sterben hunderte Soldaten russische
Kämpfer fordern bessere Ausrüstung
und Riesenchance bei den Oscars der
deutsche Kriegsfilm im Westen nichts
Neues ist 9 Mal nominiert auch als
bester Film
[Musik]
Südamerika ist derzeit begehrtes Ziel
für deutsche Politiker der
Bundespräsident war schon da der
Bundeskanzler sowie zwei Ministerinnen
jetzt sind Wirtschaftsminister Habeck
und Agrarminister Özdemir in Brasilien
denn dort gibt es viel was Deutschland
braucht Absatzmärkte Rohstoffe und
nachhaltige Energie Karl Hinterleitner
und Diana Zimmermann berichten
die größten Wasserfälle Südamerikas in
Iguazu am Dreiländereck Brasilien
Argentinien und Paraguay die Region um
das Naturwunder ist ein riesiges
Energiereservoir der halbe Subkontinent
wird vom nahegelegenen Kraftwerk Itaipu
mit Strom versorgt im Innovationszentrum
dort sind sie überzeugt dass die Zukunft
dem Wasserstoff gehört besonders
Energie sondern Wind oder Wasserkraft es
besteht die Erwartung dass wir mit den
niedrigen Kosten für Energie aus
erneuerbaren Quellen in Brasilien auch
wasserstoffwettbewerbsfähig erzeugen
können und das ist was die Welt heute
sucht Wasserstoff in großem Maßstab und
zu wettbewerbsfähigen Kosten
genau das macht Brasilien interessant
für Robert Habeck der
Wirtschaftsminister immer auf der Suche
nach neuen Energielieferanten Brasilien
sei da besonders geeignet
und Deutschland in Europa
suchen also verstärkt neue
Handelsbeziehungen neue
handelspartnerschaften auf einem fairen
nachhaltigen und
klimaneutralen Niveau
Brasilien sei stabil und bietet gerade
jetzt langfristige gemeinsame
Perspektiven nach Jahren unter
bolzenario einen Präsidenten also dem
die Demokratie so wenig am Herzen lag
wie der Klimaschutz ist Brasilien wieder
zurück Diplomaten aus aller Welt geben
sich hier die Klinke in die Hand und
auch für die deutsche Regierung unter
dem Eindruck von Klimakrise und
russischem Angriffskrieg ist das
Rohstoff und ressourcenreiche Land so
attraktiv
morgen geht es weiter nach Brasilia wenn
es gut läuft dann hat Robert Habeck am
Ende seiner Reise einen neuen Partner in
Südamerika gewonnen
in die Ukraine dort hält der blutige
Stellungskrieg im Osten des Landes
unvermindert an und das obwohl die
Munition auf beiden Seiten knapp wird in
einem Video fordern russische Soldaten
von ihrem Präsidenten bessere Ausrüstung
besonders betroffen von den Kämpfen ist
weiterhin die Stadt bachmut dort beginnt
der Bericht von Noten leinhaus
Häuser Gerippe und Trümmerberge sind das
was bleibt im Süden von bachmut hatten
sich ukrainische Scharfschützen
verschanzt jetzt drückt hier die
russische Söldnertruppe Wagner vor
wir mussten die Häuser zerstören um
überhaupt an sie heranzukommen denn die
Scharfschützen waren in fast jedem
Gebäude
die Verluste sind enorm auf beiden
Seiten in nur 24 Stunden sollen in
bachmut Hunderte gefallen sein
harsche Kritik übt wagner-chef
gregorschin Russland Armeeführung
versorge seine Kämpfer nicht ausreichend
mit Munition einen Hilferuf an keine
Chef Putin verbreiten diese Reservisten
im Nachrichtenkanal Telegramm mit
schlechter Ausrüstung und beinahe
unvorbereitet würden sie in den Kampf
geschickt wir verweigern uns nicht das
Gebiet zu verteidigen
ungerechtfertigtes Risiko aber lehnen
wir ab mit Maschinengewehren kämpfen wir
gegen Panzer Mörser und Scharfschützen
auch auf ukrainischer Seite fehlen
zunehmend Munition und Technik dringend
hoffen Sie hier auf die versprochenen
Leopard 2 Panzer
alle hier warten darauf auch meine
Brigade erst vor kurzem haben wir unsere
Leute zur Ausbildung am Leopard 2 A6
geschickt
wichtige Brücken im Kampfgebiet um
bachmut haben die Ukraine zerstört für
den Fall dass die Russen nach Westen
durchbrechen sollten
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat
ein Programm angekündigt um longkowit
und Impfschäden zu untersuchen und zu
behandeln dem ZDF sagte er dazu sei er
mit dem Haushaltsausschuss in
Verhandlungen außerdem erwarte er dass
sich Pharmaunternehmen angesichts der so
wörtlich
exorbitanten Gewinne an anfallenden
Kosten beteiligen das ganze Gespräch
gibt später im heute journal
trotz der massiven Proteste im Land hat
in Frankreich der Senat die geplante
Rentenreform gebilligt dem Gesetz muss
nun noch die Nationalversammlung
zustimmen dort hat die Regierung aber
keine Mehrheit und ist auf die Stimmen
der konservativen angewiesen seit Wochen
demonstrieren die Franzosen dagegen dass
das Renteneintrittsalter von 62 auf 64
Jahre angehoben wird
fünf Monate waren sie auf der
Internationalen Raumstation ISS jetzt
sind zwei Frauen und zwei Männer zurück
auf der Erde nach rund 19 Stunden Flug
landete die amerikanisch japanisch
russische Crew vor der Küste Floridas
die Zusammenarbeit auf der ISS ist einer
der wenigen Bereiche in denen die USA
und Russland noch zusammenarbeiten
in knapp sechs Stunden geht es los zum
95 Mal werden die Oscars verliehen und
noch nie bekam dabei ein deutscher Film
eine so große Bühne das Remake des
kriegsfilms im Westen nichts Neues ist
in neuen Kategorien nominiert unter
anderem als erste deutsche Produktion in
der Königsklasse bester Film aus
Hollywood Elma de wissen
mit Grausen denkt Oskar super Fan Vivian
als letzte Jahr will Smith Ohrfeige für
Chris Rock weniger Drama soll es hier
diesmal geben die Oscars war optisch
aufgefrischt aber der Teppich ist
erstmals nicht mehr rot dafür könnte
historisch werden
Katzen Knüller die Rekord Milliarden
einflogen oder er schwammen der verrückt
verwirrende Überraschungserfolg
everything everywhere all at once man
weiß echt gut
im Westen nichts Neues
das erste Weltkriegs Epos unglaublich
brutal 9 mal für den Oscar nominiert die
Macher ahnten bei der Produktion noch
nichts vom Ukraine Krieg aber wollten
waren aus Sorge um die Demokratie
der spürten dass die Gesellschaften
überall wieder zersetzt wurden von von
Populismus und Nationalismus von diesen
Gift wir hielten ist für relevant
den Film zu machen und daran zu erinnern
was passieren kann wenn man dieser Form
von rechter Propaganda nicht sofort
entgegen tritt ein deutscher Beitrag
erstmals bester Film es wäre historisch
es ist kein Zufall dass eine Ohrfeige
letztes Jahr stärker nachhalte als der
beste Film die Oscars sind auf sie
müssen sich entscheiden wohin die Reise
geht entweder der Wirklichkeit
entfliehen mit Kassenschlagern wie
Maverick oder Avatar oder sich ihr
Stellen in all ihre Härte selbst für
Vivien wer hätte das gedacht dass die
Sache sonnenklar
die oskarnacht in Hollywood wer sind die
Nominierten wer hat die größten Chancen
auf die goldene Trophäe Antworten auf
all das gibt es in der ZDF heute App und
keine Trophäe gab es heute beim
deutschen für die deutschen beim
Biathlon die Männer als auch die Frauen
verpassten den massenstart-wettbewerb
den Sprung aufs Podest besonders
enttäuschend das Abschneiden von
Weltmeisterin Denise Hermann Wick
die beste deutsche Biathletin wirkt
ratlos nach ihrem Rennen allein vier
Fehler beim zweiten Schießen in
diskutabel insgesamt bei 20 Schuss nur
15 Treffer am Ende Platz 23 man weiß es
natürlich dann auch nicht wo die genau
hin und dann eine nach der anderen nicht
fällt da ja dazwischen irgendwann besser
macht es Mannschaftskollegin Vanessa
Vogt sie bleibt bei allen vier
Schießeinlagen fehlerfrei und belohnt
sich mit Platz 7 es gewinnt dorotheavira
aus Italien bei den Männern überzeugt
der Norweger Bettler Christiansen besser
deutscher wieder einmal Benedikt doll
auf Rang acht Roman Rees 14
zwei deutsche Podestplätze in Oslo
dagegen für die Nordischen Kombinierer
nach guten Sprüngen ein packendes Duell
in der Loipe zwischen den beiden
oberstdorfern Julian Schmidt und Vinzenz
Geiger um Platz 2 das Geiger für sich
entscheidet ja und wieder unschlagbar
der norwegerial Magnus Riva sein 55
weltcupsieg
Bayern Stürmer Thomas Müller soll in
dieser Saison kein Fußball Länderspiel
mehr bestreiten das erklärte
Bundestrainer haben sie flieg heute in
einem Interview vielmehr will der
dfb-coach jüngeren Spielern eine Chance
geben fliegt nannte explizit Kai havertz
vom FC Chelsea
Deutschland Handballer haben auch ihr
zweites Testspiel gegen Dänemark
verloren nach der Niederlage am Freitag
in Aarburg heute die Pleite in Hamburg
einen enttäuschendes 21 zu 28
Schlussmann Andreas Wolf verhinderte
durch seine Paraden sogar ein Debakel
gegen den Weltmeister bester deutscher
Werfer Juri Knorr mit neuen Treffern
ja also die beiden ersten Spiele nach
der WM deutlich verloren bisschen
enttäuschend es wird wieder besser
werden
fehlt noch das Wetter im Süden länger
sonnig sonst wechselnd oder stark
bewölkt und zeitweise Regen am
Nachmittag im Westen und Südwesten
einzelne Gewitter starker Südwestwind im
Nordwesten und im Bergland Sturmböen
Höchstwerte zwischen 11 und 22 Grad
das heute journal um viertel vor zehn
mit Christian Sievers und dem Gespräch
mit dem Gesundheitsminister über
Impfschäden das gesamte heute-team sagt
danke und tschüss und wünscht Ihnen
einen guten Start in die neue Woche und
hier übernimmt jetzt Chuck unter labella
die mit Berlin direkt